le grand public l'a découvert dans la
comédie musicale les dix commandements
de pascal obispo le chanteur pablo
villafranca se produit aujourd'hui dans
un spectacle à dimension humaine
il prête sa voix à la compagnie chinoise
à la vente urine pour un compte
alliant danse théâtre chant et cirque
sur scène ils sont douze artistes nous
l'appellation qu'on lui a donné ses
comptes acrobatiquement musicale et
c'est effectivement pluridisciplinaire
ça mélange le chant le théâtre les arts
du cirque la magie la danse
c'est l'histoire d'adrien qui est un
ancien clown devenu sdf parce qu'il
s'est passé un drame dans sa vie et qui
en fait
parce que il ya un cirque il s'installe
à côté de lui va petit à petit revenir
vers sa vie d'avant donc c'est toute
l'histoire et tout le cheminement du
justement un peu le paradoxe entre le
clown qui est un personnage qui fait
plutôt rire qui inspire confiance le
côté très positif de ce personnage et le
personnage du sdf qui nous ont mis dans
l'inconscient collectif à quelque chose
à bord un couple négation l'histoire
originale de ce conte drôle et touchant
et signer un autre bettina mari auteur
pour la télévision elle présente
quotidiennement une émission de jeunesse
sur le câble au théâtre elle met en
scène les artistes qui donnent naissance
à ses textes
moi je suis vraiment dans la direction
d'acteurs dans l'intention serra et il
ya la chorégraphie à côté après le but
c'est deux de tout mettre ensemble nous
tous rassemblés pour justement avoir un
spectacle fluide en fait qu'on voit un
ensemble et je pense que c'est ça qui
sort du lot en ce moment c'est ce côté
magique grand sens du kansas et le côté
spectacle en fait il n'y a pas ce pas
une pièce de théâtre ou du chant ou
danser au moins un spectacle entier quoi
pour découvrir
adrien où la vie en équilibre trois
dates à retenir les 11 12 et 19 janvier
à la salle blanche de castille à poissy